oh are you doing magic let's see then
think you know everything there is to
know about the one and only hermione
granger
even the biggest potterheads will be
surprised by these little-known facts
jk rowling has revealed some fascinating
secrets about our number one girl
and they prove that hermione is one of
the most misunderstood characters in
harry potter
from her family background to her love
life we're deep diving into things about
hermione that
everyone gets wrong well you can tell
ronald i'm not an owl
emma watson's casting meant fans assumed
hermione was white
and there was a lot of chatter when noma
doomswenie was cast in the role for the
harry potter and the cursed child stage
play
in london but in december 2015 rowling
tweeted canon
brown eyes frizzy hair and very clever
white skin was never specified
rowling loves black hermione and she
told the observer newspaper hermione can
be a black woman with my absolute
blessing
and enthusiasm it's a heartbreaking
moment when hermione uses the obliviate
spell on her parents
she's doing it to protect them of course
and many fans think hermione never saw
her parents again
after they started their new life in
australia but in a bloomsbury web chat
in 2007
a fan asked jk rowling if hermione was
able to find her parents and undo the
memory damage
the author answered yes she brought them
home straight away
rowling also explained that hermione
hadn't wiped her parents memories
instead she bewitched them to make them
believe that they are different people
hermione and harry have an important
thing in common they're both an only
child
but in a world book day chat in 2004 jk
rowling revealed that she'd always
planned that hermione would have a
younger sister
however the author never got around to
giving the little sister an appearance
and by that point it felt like it was
too late to add her into the later books
in that world book day chat in 2004 the
author also revealed that hermione's
middle name
was jane but by the time it was actually
mentioned in the final book when
dumbledore's will is read out
rowling changed it to gene there are a
couple of possible reasons for this
dolores umbridge had been given the
middle name jane in book five
and rowling gave birth to a daughter
mackenzie in 2005 and gave her the
middle name
gene to hermione gene granger
i leave my copy of the tales of
beedle the bard it's not just hermione's
middle name that rowling changed her
mind about
the author revealed in an article on her
website that in the dim and distant past
hermione's surname was
puckle so why did rolling change it
because it didn't suit her at all
so the author switched it for something
a little bit less frivolous
it's easy to assume that know-it-all
hermione is very self-confident in her
abilities but that's not actually the
case
deep down jk rowling revealed on her
website that she knows hermione was seen
by other people
as a right little know-it-all however
she hopes it's clear that underneath
hermione's swattiness
there is a lot of insecurity and a great
fear of failure
her bogart proves that mcgonagall
telling her she's failed
behaving like a babbling bumbling band
of baboons
hermione was top of most of her classes
but that wasn't her major motivation for
studying so hard
on jk rowling's official website it was
revealed that part of the reason
hermione worked so hard was that she was
terrified of getting things wrong
and letting people down it's a natural
assumption that being intelligent was
the most important thing to hermione but
then why wasn't she sorted into
ravenclaw
after all in the order of the phoenix
hermione says the sorting hat did
seriously consider
ravenclaw for her but as hermione tells
harry in the first book brains aren't
everything
it's loyalty and bravery both gryffindor
traits that count
friendship and bravery on the topic of
hermione's house
if you thought the sorting hat was in
charge of hermione becoming a gryffindor
think again the film shows a quick
straightforward sorting but rowling
revealed on pottermore that hermione was
almost
a hat stall a student whose sorting
takes longer than five minutes
because hermione showed a strong
preference for gryffindor on the
hogwarts express
saying it sounds by far the best it's
likely that's what influenced the hat
if you need any more evidence that
brains aren't everything to hermione
then you only have to look at her
attraction to victor crum
that was definitely a heart overhead
situation
they weren't compatible with hermione
telling harry that victor's not
particularly loquacious
mostly he watches me study we like to
think of hermione as knowing everything
and being level-headed but she can be
duped by charm after all let's not
forget how she was fooled by gilderoy
lockhart
she fond over him in class not realizing
that he was a con man
of course hermione and ron's
relationship is a major talking point
amongst fans
for many reasons but did you know that
jk rowling wanted hermione to be the one
in charge of their romantic developments
when a fan asked the author what she
felt when she finally wrote the kissing
scene
rowling replied that she loved writing
it and loved the fact that hermione took
the initiative
i'll do the introduction that's all
you're honestly the most wonderful
person i've ever met
jk rowling insisted that they kept the
troll scene in the first book when her
editor suggested
she cut it why so because as the author
says hermione bless her is so very
annoying in the early part of the
philosopher's stone that i really felt
it needed something
literally huge to bring her together
with harry and ron that was emma
watson's favorite scene in the movie
because she got to perform her own
stunts
i went looking for the troll i read
about them and thought i could handle it
of course potterheads know that
hermione's wand is made of vinewood with
a dragon heartstring core
but did you know that reveals her true
character jk rowling used a celtic tree
calendar for the symbolism behind each
wood
and vine symbolizes passionate emotions
all characters names are important of
course but jk rowling put a lot of extra
thought into hermiones
the author explained in a 1999 radio
interview that she consciously set out
to choose a fairly unusual name for
hermione that was just in case somewhere
out there there was a jane with big
front teeth who was really swatty and
annoying
the name actually comes from
shakespeare's a winter tale although she
isn't like that character
rowling thought it seemed the sort of
name that a pair of professional
dentists who like to prove how clever
they were
would choose and what exactly did i say
may i ask
my name in the early days rowling used
to get asked how to pronounce hermione's
name more than anything
to the point that the author even said
she wished she'd called her jane
rowling revealed that she used to hear
her myoni a lot
but her favorite was herme wan she found
it really cute but she also cunningly
inserted the proper pronunciation
into goblet of fire when hermione tells
victor how to say it properly
most fans will know jk rowling based
hermione on herself but did you know
that the character isn't actually an
exact replica
in a radio interview in 1999 the author
described hermione as a caricature of
what she was like when she was 11.
she went so far as to call hermione a
borderline genius and a real
exaggeration
because she wasn't that clever rowling
also hoped she wasn't as annoying as the
incredible know-it-all
stop stop stop you're going to take
someone's eye
out while hermione was good at a lot of
subjects she wasn't good at everything
despite many fans thinking she's top of
the class in all subjects
take flying for example in their first
flying lesson with madame hooch hermione
struggled to get her broomstick to raise
to her hand
professor mcgonagall gave hermione a
time turner in prisoner of azkaban so
she could take more classes
but of course hermione and harry used it
for far more important tasks
saving buckbeak and sirius did you
assume hermione kept the magical object
jk rowling revealed on pottermore in
2015 that she'd made a problem for
herself by including time travel
so she solved the problem by getting
hermione to give back the time turner
and then
the author smashed all remaining time
turners during the battle in the
department of mysteries
when a fan asked jk rowling what animals
she would turn into if she were an
animagus she replied that she gave
hermione her ideal animagus as her
patronus because it's her favorite
animal
and that's the otter we see hermione
conjure in the room of requirement
in the order of the phoenix rowling even
voted for an orphan daughter to be
called luna
at least no one on the gryffindor team
had to buy their way in
they got it on pure talent what
surprised you the most about hermione
sound off in the comments below and be
sure to give this video a big thumbs up
to show your love for all things harry
potter thanks for watching